a houseplant is not going to get very  old with compared to us because the  information processing is so much slower  so they're not going to be very smart  but at the level of ecosystems it's  conceivable that there is quite  considerable intelligence and then I  stumbled on this notion that our  ancestors thought that one day in  Fairyland equals seven years in human  land which is taught in the oldness  and also I this at some point I revised  my notion of what the spirit is for  instance is a spirit is it's an old word  for the operating system for an  autonomous robot  and the event this world was invented  the only autonomous robots that were  known were people and plants and animals  and nation states and ecosystems